comme l'année dernière après plusieurs
mois de restriction l'été fait place à
des fêtes sauvages sur l'espace public
au départ bon enfant elles sont
toutefois fréquemment le théâtre de
violences et de débordements c'est un
sujet qui m'ont fait beaucoup réagir et
vous êtes plusieurs comme cet internaute
à vous demander pourquoi les
organisateurs ne sont pas poursuivis
en réalité ce n'est pas si simple et on
vous explique pourquoi
dans ce nouvel épisode de factures si
ces fêtes sauvages ne sont pas nouvelles
elles ont désormais un nom soirée projet
x l'appellation fait référence à un film
américain sortie en 2012 dans laquelle
une soirée promu sur les réseaux sociaux
échappe totalement au contrôle de ses
organisateurs poussée à la fois par
l'allègement des restrictions sanitaires
la fin des cours l'ambiance estivale ou
encore l'absence de discothèques ces
fêtes sont très populaire notamment
auprès des jeunes
les organisateurs de ces soirées type
projet x en fait c'est laid c'est les
mêmes gens qu les participants c'est à
dire c'est mes élèves
ça va en gros de 16 à 20 21 ans malgré
leur anonymat l'envi de faire le buzz et
c'est de faire tourner une information
et puis de créer à soi un événement qui
va revenir des centaines ou des milliers
de personnes dégradation insultes
tabassage en dépit du jeune âge des
participants des affrontements avec la
très fréquemment lors de ces soirées des
violences entre jeunes mais également à
l'égard des forces de l'ordre ce qu'il
ya c'est effectivement la rencontre de
plusieurs mondes de plusieurs classes
sociales il ya des lycées plutôt dans
des endroits huppés de la capitale qui
sont ou l'information a tourné avec des
jeunes qui veulent participer à ces
soirées et puis la même information va
tourner dans un lycée un petit peu plus
de banlieue un peu plus difficile et c
est donc là c'est effectivement la
rencontre de plusieurs mondes parfois
c'est juste différences sociales qui
peut amener à des rixes etc ou n'importe
quel type de provocation comme on sait
en faire un stage là ou bien parfois
celle envie de dépouiller des petits
bourgeois en fait des petits délinquants
qui vont prendre des iphone qui vont
faire le plein de
tout ce qui vole en général dans ces
soirées des groupes d'individus qui
viennent se joindre aux participants
dans le but de commettre des délits
malheureusement aussi on l'a vu encore
récemment des violences des agressions
soit envers les participants soient des
fois même envers d'autres d'autres
bandes rivales qui viennent également se
joindre à cette fin et on se retrouve
après avec des affrontements en plein
milieu et qu'une fête qui dégénère et
qui devient pour le coup hyperviolente
pour comprendre pourquoi les forces de
leurs peines à contrer ces fêtes
sauvages
il faut comprendre comment elles sont
organisées les invitations sont lancées
sur les réseaux sociaux par le biais de
compte instagram snap chatou encore tik
tok chacun invite ses amis à participer
à l'événement afin d'être le plus
nombreux possible
le lieu du rassemblement le plus souvent
en extérieur est généralement divulguer
aux derniers mandats des réseaux sociaux
est énorme et totalement énorme puisque
vous avez une facilité d'organisation
quelques minutes on pouvait mobiliser
tellement de gens par action soit de
simples qui devient virale à nous les
déplacer une grande population sur un
endroit nommé le fait que ces soirées
projet qui s'organisent en un temps très
court et que l'intégralité de la
communication repose sur les réseaux
sociaux complexifie le travail des
forces de l'ordre la rapidité
l'instantanéité fait prendre
quoi qu'il arrive c'est surtout
automatique aux forces de l'ordre un
temps de retard sur six être si ça
arrivait de détecter à l'avancé par une
fuite si c'est plus lourd
on sera quoiqu'il arrive toujours un
restaurant car le rapport de force n'est
jamais en notre faveur si on arrive à
détecter en amont
l'organisation de ces fêtes qui mutile
qui ont souvent un caractère il y a
autre point la police fait face à un
manque de moyens pour contrer ce
phénomène problèmes qu'ont les
enquêteurs c'est effectivement fins et
les moyens de dire que c'est de la cyber
destination c'est très long c'est assez
coûteux et pour les postes actuels dans
la police cyber estimation il ya
beaucoup d'autres dossiers qui sont très
importants qui sont plus importants en
fait il ya des dossiers de
pédocriminalité il ya des dossiers de
gros trafics de stupéfiants etc les
moyens en l'absence de drame
effectivement son sont limités c'est
particulièrement difficile de pouvoir
localiser le début de ces soirées
puisque
tout part des réseaux sociaux à la
difficulté pour nous c'est de pouvoir
identifier qui a lancé l'invitation
l'accès à l'information sur les réseaux
sociaux et particulièrement verrouillé
écrite et qui nous complique davantage
la tâche de la même manière inutile de
côté sur les plates formes pour aider la
police dans ses investigations leur
marge de manoeuvre est limitée puisque
la protection des données entre en jeu
qui plus est l'absence de représentant
légal de ces entreprises en france
complexifie les démarches judiciaires
toujours est il que les forces de
l'ordre espèrent une diminution de ce
phénomène avec la réouverture des
discothèques et les départs en vacances
[Musique]